yeah it's like yeah i'll say it earlier
like japanese taxis they just stop
anywhere have you noticed that
they they are the jocks when i tell them
to stop around somewhere
they'll they like take that literally
and they'll stop in the middle of the
[ __ ] busy highway
and they'll be like all right here you
are i'm like bro what are you doing
get through like a side road if you
don't specify like can you stop
like down the road if you just say stop
they'll be like okay stopping
they stop that's why you realize that
yeah yeah yeah if i say it like
tomorrow i'm like we're in the middle of
an intersection maybe you should like
move forward a bit he did that when we
went to the we underwent ramen last
night
and then he stopped at the intersection
yeah just stopped and i'm like i'm not
getting out of the car we're in the
[ __ ] intersection
like bro it's so weird
i i don't know because they follow road
rules so strictly here but then for some
reason taxi drivers
uh just don't and it's it's funny
because i noticed on the british
government website when you go to japan
it says
be careful of taxi drivers because they
just stop anywhere
especially when driving yeah because if
you're behind a taxi driver in japan
you're driving be careful
he will probably just stop like full
full force just
full of it's crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like the
like road rules or like who has the
right away kind of confusing me
sometimes and
okay zebra cross oh yeah yeah zebra
crossings in every country
have a different meaning and i don't
know what it means in japan
like exactly so to explain in the uk if
there's a zebra crossing
the pedestrian always has the right of
way yeah yeah
like you never need to fear for your
life
you're taught to stop uh as a driver you
stop even if you see someone walking
near you yeah like slow down
exactly but you know in in like
southeast asia asia
zebra crossings mean nothing it's a
suggestion it's it's a suggestion
in japan i don't know what it means
either sometimes they stop
they're supposed to stop but they don't
i've had instances though where i've
stood
like at the front of the several
crossing right when they weren't going
to stop and like five cars just passed
by i'm like can i can i
you have to like start walking in the
road and then they'll stop so i realize
like
i'm playing [ __ ] chicken i've got to
walk in the road and be like halt
i have the right of ways
i don't know why you'd think that you
know considering how strict their
road rules are yeah and everyone leaves
so much room between the cars here
i noticed that it's like three cars yeah
in the uk it's like this much
but in japan it's like all right leave a
call at least a call that's why i'm kind
of glad that japan doesn't have like
roundabouts can you imagine oh god
like just how much of a [ __ ] no one
would like no one would give away
everyone would just be waiting for
someone to come here no no
please please no because like there was
this like i don't know if it's an
actual road rule and i want to preface i
don't know if it's an actual road rule
but in australia we were taught and some
people were taught
that when you're in a roundabout right
usually it's like whoever's in the
roundabout first right it's basically
like
once you're in the roundabout you have
to give away to whoever is in the
roundabout right yeah
but in australia some people were taught
that like oh no you always have to give
way to the person on your right
and i'm just like but then what if
there's four people left around about
see them and they're far enough away on
the right it's like i guess go
this is what i hate roundabouts yeah
yeah like super like
rock solid logic that you can apply
australia's the land of [ __ ]
roundabouts
it's kind of like you just got to be
like americans like what the [ __ ] are
you guys talking about
yeah basically you just like kind of
have to you see a car coming you're like
do i think i can get this car in gear
oh yeah yeah yeah that's that just
brings an extra layer
the worst to my drive because it's it's
like playing a quick time event
and if you fail the quick time event you
just you just crash
joey drives automatic so he's he's lucky
oh my god
the worst part is because you obviously
have to stop most of the time the
roundabout
yeah so you're like you see a car and
you're like i've seen this car i have to
quickly decide whether i can get in gear
and go yeah and if i'm fast enough to
not make that
guy slow down too much because it's just
a mess oh yeah dude it's easy for me
because i just like
can i make it yeah i'll just floor i'll
just press the go yeah